but in the meantime let's get more on
our top story and an apology and a
promise of cultural change from police
34 years on from the Hillsborough
disaster 97 football fans died as a
result of a crush at a match between
Liverpool and Nottingham Forest back in
April 1989. well I'm joined Now by Peter
scarf who's chairman of the Hillsborough
survivors support Alliance uh Peter very
good to talk to you today what is your
reaction to what the police have said
today five years after this initial
report was released
I think it's taken an awful long time
for them to get these answers
I think five years is way too long 34
years
for an apology
families have been torn apart not just
Hillsborough families who've obviously
who've lost their loved ones but
obviously Hillsborough survivors who've
lost friends as well through a suicide
and the likes
uh I just feel it's just taking far too
long for them to come back with answers
and and an apology that
I don't know I don't if it has
the strength that they say has
they've announced it a new code of
ethics
um you know to try and have a code of
openness within the police force they've
also announced a charter so that
mistakes if they are made are admitted
they said it will no longer defend the
indefensible does that give you any hope
that perhaps in the future such a thing
could not happen again it's not quite
Hillsborough law I would expect
Hillsborough law to be passed to be
honest because it's easy saying we've
learned from it we're going to correct
our mistakes we'll make sure that
accountability is there we can't cover
things up but without a law they can
what the the one thing that we haven't
heard today is a response from the
government which still hasn't given its
response to to this uh report by the
Reverend James Jones
um have you had any dealing or have your
group had any dealings with the
government do you know what is causing
this delay
there's absolutely no dealings at all
none at all
what do you feel about the fact that
it's taken so long
uh well reflecting on the the feedback
from the group themselves anger you know
people are extremely angry that it's
taken so long a
the general public who were reading you
know again about Hillsborough think that
it's it's down to Hillsborough families
and Hillsborough survivors why it's
still continuing to go on and it's not
mistakes were made and they need to be
rectified and we are not to blame
so I just feel that
it's taken way too long and they need to
do more they do need to do more
the the fact that there isn't a response
from the government how much harder is
that making it for the families and and
the relatives and the friends of those
who died to to move on and perhaps put a
put a full stop at the end of this awful
period of their lives
it's it's almost impossible to move on
it's you know we know that if they do
come up with some sort of a statement
from the government and you know even if
it's a formal apology from them
again it's too late it's taken too long
and of course how long are we going to
wait we've waited five years for this
well 34 years from the disaster itself
and we're still waiting and if the
government's I I really don't know if
they're ever going to say anything
okay Peter scoff chairman of the
Hillsborough Survivor support Alliance
are very kindly to join us today thank
you thank you